the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video
well my friends it looks like we have
another official announcement from hbo
this information was released only a few
hours ago
i saw this breaking news over on
facebook on the game of thrones verified
account
they said fire will reign the hbo
original series house of the dragon
is officially in production now what has
me very excited is what it says after
that
it says coming soon to hbo max in 2022
it looks like house of the dragon is
still on schedule which is great news
i know i was a little worried when
everything was either shut down or
locked down but even with all of the
craziness that has been happening house
of the dragon will still be here on our
television screens as early as next year
that is amazing now if you look at the
photos they released
you can see some of the main actors are
sitting down for their first table read
they're even social distancing let's
have a look at who is here then maybe we
will look at how some of the fans are
reacting to this news
emma darcy is here and as you can see
she will be one of the main characters
in this series
rhaenyra targaryen was named as the heir
to the iron throne by her father
king viserys targaryen but after he dies
all hell breaks loose
now i won't get into all of that here
because i have already made some videos
about that
let's see what some of the fans are
saying about this actress
brett says he is excited to see her
shine a few of them also said they loved
her and truth seekers
i have not seen that myself in fact i
haven't really seen this actress in
anything so i'm looking forward to
seeing how well she does with this
material
it looks like most of the facebook fans
are excited for her
actor steve tucson is here as well he
will be lord corliss velaryon
also known as the sea snake now for
those of you who don't know
i just uploaded a video about his house
early this morning
there were some photos that already
leaked out from one of the sets
if you have not seen that video yet i
would definitely check that out
i will add it to the end of this video
that way you don't have to leave and
click on another one
now obviously if you already saw that
video then don't worry about staying all
the way until the very end
now let's see what some of the fans are
saying about him mathis says
big oof on the looks but on the other
hand coreless velaryon is a character
with a lot of depth
and a huge role in the story i will
judge him on his acting performance
alone
there have been a lot of fans upset with
the casting choice by hbo
i honestly don't mind i just want to see
him done well
i know some fans believe the characters
should be white
well not just white but also have the
features of the valyrians
now i have seen different arguments for
this some say his character description
never outright says what he looks like
while others say well his children are
white so he should be white as well
george rr martin is a co-creator of the
show maybe he gave them the green light
to do this
maybe george likes the idea we just
don't know
that's why i will wait and see how the
actor does himself before i go
criticizing this decision
for now i'm okay with it patty considine
is here as well
he is king viserys targaryen father of
rhaenyra targaryen
and husband of allison hightower it will
be their conflict over the iron throne
that leads to the targaryen civil war
which will be the main focus of the show
it looks like most of the fans are
excited to see this actor in a series
one guy even says that he looks like the
hound now i don't know about that
i guess he looks like the hound if he
was a vegan i did see this actor in the
outsiders and i thought he did a great
job
so i am looking forward to seeing how he
does in this show
then we have matt smith who is here also
matt smith will be daemon targaryen
one of the best characters in the song
of ice and fire universe
i have only watched a few episodes of
the crown so far but i think he is a
great actor from what i have seen
i think he will do a great job with the
character olivia cook is here for the
first table read
as i said before she is allison
hightower the wife of king viserys
targaryen
and the daughter of his hand of the king
serado hightower
now speaking of serato hightower he will
be portrayed by
rhys evens now i hope i said that right
and if not i will learn it soon enough
once i get more familiar with seeing and
hearing these actors names
over and over again i'm honestly not
familiar with this actor's work either
but by looking at what some of the fans
say we should be expecting him to do a
great job
he has been in a lot of different movies
and television shows
so the man does have a lot of experience
i am very excited to see how all of this
continues to unfold
as i have said in other videos i will be
here to document all of this
every single step of the way it won't be
long before these actors are reading
these lines on set
as they are filming the actual scenes
hopefully they're able to stay on
schedule
so we can see the first episode next
year it's all happening again my friends
we are about to be back in westeros very
soon
i for one am very happy about this if
any more information is released i will
make a video on it as soon as i can
as always i want to thank all of you for
stopping by to watch my video
i hope all of you have a great day i
will see you again very soon
bye
alright my friends i have some really
good news for the game of thrones fans
who are excited to see house of the
dragon
as you all know hbo has been developing
this successor show for many years
it's actually the first idea george rr
martin brought to hbo when game of
thrones was nearing its end
this is something i have been making
videos about every step of the way
now for those of you who have been
living under a rock house of the dragon
will be a new hbo series based on george
rr martin's fire and blood
it's set roughly 170 years before the
events in game of thrones
this is when the targaryens nearly drove
their own house into extinction over who
should sit on the iron throne
the dance of the dragons a stupid name
for a targaryen civil war where my
ancestors
danced away my birthright before the war
house targaryen counted 18 dragons
by the end we had two and nearly as few
targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again
this major conflict set sibling against
sibling and dragon against dragon
now unlike game of thrones this story
ends in spectacular fashion
but i won't get into all of that here
i've already made some videos about that
if you have been watching all of my
other house of the dragon videos
then you know filming should have
already begun we already know the show
runners are writer ryan condell
and director miguel sapochnick who is
famously known for directing amazing
game of thrones episodes like heart home
battle of the bastards and the winds of
wonder
george r martin has also signed on as
one of the show's co-creators
they've even brought back the incredible
composer from the original series
it really does feel like hbo is setting
this show up for success
house of the dragon is getting almost
all of the same ingredients that made
game of thrones so great
these are only some of the reasons why i
am so excited for this new show
now as far as i know hbo still hasn't
found enough actors to fill
every single character that will be in
house of the dragon
at least the ones who are in the first
season i have made videos about the
actors they have hired so far but there
are still a lot of other characters in
this show
i'm hoping they're just holding back
that information because like i said at
the beginning of this video
filming should have already started now
if this photo is what i think it is
we may now have a glimpse of one of
their locations where many scenes will
most likely be filmed
game of thrones fans have spotted a film
set in england that looks to show the
sigil of a noble house
that will have a significant role in
house of the dragon some of you might
have seen this somewhere already
but this image has me very excited
because now it really feels like things
are about to start happening
now this series is about to come to life
and i for one cannot wait to see how
everything looks
located over in cornwall england fans
have spotted a new set that looks very
game of thronesy if you know what i mean
some of the locals had not only seen but
also photographed signs of warner
brothers building a new set that did
evoke the fantasy world of westeros
earlier this week
according to the metro uk this aligns
with the shooting schedule for house of
the dragon
and one element from the photos may show
a strong link to the series
a sigil that matches that of house
velaryon
the best image of the set in the seaside
county of cornwall
england shows a stone arch with a
herotic crest engraved at its top
the animal in the carving looks to be a
hippocampus
it's a mythical creature that has the
head and four legs of a horse
and the tail of a fish also called a
seahorse readers of george r martin's
fire and blood
a compilation of westeros's history that
serves as the basis for the series
identified the seahorse as the sigil for
house velaryon
although velaryon sigil is generally
depicted as a sea horse from the real
world
the modification into a mythical sea
creature is one that could be reasonably
expected from a tv
adaptation of the book's canon if the
photo does indicate house velaryon
the set with the archway may be the
island of driftmark
home to lord corliss velaryon princess
rhaenyra summoned her own
black council with her was her uncle and
husband damon targaryen
considered by many to be the most
dangerous man in westeros
few lords supported her but the greatest
of these was corliss valerian
who controlled the largest fleet in the
realm and his targaryen wife rhaenys
the old king's sister now although high
ranked among the noble families of the
era
the valerions were eventually eradicated
and had no mention in game of thrones
now all of these photos started leaking
online a few days ago when cornwall live
reported that warner brothers filming
trucks had been unloading near the
village of hollywell
a region in the southwest of england you
can see the warner brothers trucks in
one of these photos
for those of you that don't know warner
brothers owns hbo
unfortunately there wasn't anyone
working on this set who would confirm
what they were there to
film but that was to be expected like i
said
house of the dragons should start
filming this month and they will have to
film on sets that do look like this
it would also make sense that house
valerion would be located near the sea
which this set just so happens to be
when you add in the fact that warner
brothers is here near the set
it all starts to make sense unless i see
something else that says otherwise
i fully believe this is where house of
the dragon will be filming some of their
scenes
very very soon this also isn't the only
bit of evidence that's interesting
earlier this month there was a casting
call where they were looking for male
actors who had longer hair and longer
beards
they were also looking for women that
had long natural hair
now what makes this really interesting
is the fact that they said they needed
these actors to film scenes for a
medieval drama
in cornwall england exactly where the
set is located
we will never get an official
confirmation from hbo
but this seems obvious to me i for one
won't be surprised when more photos leak
online very soon
showing some of the actors on this set
who we know will be in the show
like i say in all of my other update
videos i will be here to document all of
this
every step of the way just like i did
with game of thrones
so if you'd like to stay up to date on
things like this make sure you subscribe
now
because this is only the first of many
photos that will come out during the
filming
of house of the dragon it won't be long
before photos start leaking online every
single day
and it won't only be photos of empty or
unfinished sets
we will begin to see photos of the
actors actually acting out the scenes
and the big battles it happened with
game of thrones
and it will happen with this show as
well now i usually make videos on all of
this information the day it is released
but i have been in the middle of writing
my own version of game of thrones season
9
so i am a little late on this update
until some more information comes out i
will get back to writing my next episode
i want to thank all of you for showing
love on my recent videos
i'm glad that most of you have been
liking them i also want to shout out all
of my new subscribers
as well as all of my new patreon members
i cannot thank all of you enough
i hope i see all of you here for my next
video have a great day everyone
i will see you soon bye
um
[Music]
you